welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Spider-Man across the spider
versus just a few weeks away Sony's
dropping near daily promos and clips
across social platforms across
International markets yet still somehow
we only have the Vegas sense of the plot
of this two hour 16 minute movie and
even then it's just one part of a
two-part event that will conclude with
the beyond the spiderverse film in 2024.
now I've done you the service of coming
through all of these promo clips for
across the spiderverse to condense them
down into just the essential takeaways
and the most essential animation details
we could find so far and I'm gonna break
down those details for you and be sure
to subscribe to my deep dive Channel
because over there at the end of May I
will be doing a re-watch in Deep dive of
2018's into the spider-verse followed by
a release Day Live stream breakdown of
across the spider-verse on June 2nd the
best way to support the scoring network
is to grab a Multiverse dive shirt from
the deep dive collection on nerd
riot.shot okay first we gotta talk about
the most mysterious new character of
this film The Spot Jonathan own voiced
by Jason Schwartzman let's take a look
at the compiled footage that we have so
far should be simple enough give me your
money so are you like a cow or a
Dalmatian Spider-Man
I am
spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
so the spot turns out pretty clumsy with
this portal Powers unable to portal into
the ATM and instead portaline passed it
his arm leaning into a bagged bread so
the slices fall out of his belly he
seems like someone new to the scene
someone's still coming into his powers
based on the art aesthetic of ink blots
and Splats I have a theory on what this
guy really is but let's just appreciate
the animation details here as miles
fights them under water some of the
stuff in the bodega it looks like
follows him a coffee cup a mug and a
bagel or a donut bagel this will spill
into a fight between these two on a
rooftop where Miles proves pretty Adept
at dodging all the blows including
squeezing between the spots downward
kick and his upward punch this is what
we call threading the needle all this is
happening while miles is late for a
parent-teacher conference the two of
them actually Arc through portals behind
them outside the school catching one of
those flying geese with them and the
three of them dump into a cafe with a
bunch of soap suds in one of those geese
attacking them as they're slipping
around I don't think I want this costume
anymore that's one of the deepest Voice
kids I've ever heard he wears a dark
miles mask his sister wears a red Peter
Parker Spider-Man mask so the two of
them are playing like the Buddy swipping
together and since Lord and Miller love
to hide animation jokes in everything on
Miles dad's Jefferson smartphones text
history he wrote in all caps this is in
pork Edge and then he tried to correct
it in fourth Kent and then finally
important but we have to talk about a
very very brief shot of the spot that
Lord Miller have been sharing on social
media a much darker evolution of the
character in which his art design
envelops the whole world around him
making it all chaotic smears of paint as
a spot switches to inverse colors now
black with white spots if this looks
familiar to you the spot's black outline
with this colorful Cloud background
looks just like miles is no expectations
wall art from the 2018 film so what does
this mean is the spot using miles's own
subconscious against him like his love
for art and Miles longing for the
simpler days with his uncle Aaron or
could the spot actually be a
manifestation of miles's own
subconscious and that's why Miguel
O'Hara considers him so dangerous and
refuses to let miles join the spider's
Society like miles may represent some
kind of cosmic imbalance someone who
became a Spider-Man through some might
say an accident and didn't have to go
through the archetypal journey of losing
a parental figure and maybe Miguel and
the spider society would say he has to
lose a parent in order to right that
wrong now Father's Day is coming up fast
and if you want to get your father a
gift he'll use every day you should
check out ridge ridge has reinvented the
wallet and it is a massive improvement
over the bulky dad wallets of yesteryear
the rich wallet is slim but expands to
hold up to 12 cards plus cash you can
fit everything you need in here Ridge
wallet's coming over 30 colors in Styles
including carbon fiber burnt titanium
forged Ember and burnt Damascus plus
these wallets are designed with the 21st
century in mind each wallet is built
with RFID blocking materials that'll
protect your info from digital
pickpockets and has an optional air tag
attachment so you'll never lose your
wallet again find the best Father's Day
gift by going to ridge.com new rockstars
and right now you can save up to 40
through June 15th one more time that's
Ridge com slash new rockstars a few new
shots to point out we finally hear a
line from spider Punk Hobie Brown voiced
by Daniel kaluya how are you even cooler
under your mask I was just cool the
whole time I love the art design of
Bobby Brown piercings and studs
everywhere and a monochrome color
palette just like the art style of punk
rock concert posters that get Mass
printed and papered over all walls and
posts causing these posters to dry and
peel in the sun there's also some
interesting shots of miles and Margot
Kess AKA spider bite from Earth 22191 a
virtual reality world where she fights
cyber crime there seems to be a mission
that she and Miles might go on together
as miles uses his invisibility and we
actually see the moment they meet from
Spider-Man oh no way all of us are yeah
both miles and Margo admit the spider
sense wavy lines which might just be
what happens every time two new spider
people meet each other no no you might
say there's kind of a pheromonal
connection there but the setting is what
interests me about this shot they appear
to be in a room with spider villains
entombed in a kind of amber colored
cocoon with spider web shapes forming
the shards of it the closest to them
actually has spiked Bangles looks like
the ones worn by Green Goblin and into
the spider-verse in 2018. this could be
Miguel's permanent prison for beans that
are just too threatening to the
Multiverse I bring it up because in
several other promo shots it looks like
miles is being sealed up in a similar
type of cocoon now if you're new spider
things revealed as part of the big chase
throughout the spider Society Lobby can
this day get any weirder I guess it can
yep that was spider cat and spider Rex
since all the other spider Heroes except
miles wear these gadgets on their bodies
somewhere spider cat wears it on its
tail spider X wears it on his little arm
and I love how his whole body is painted
in the red and blue color scheme and he
leaps at the camera to Chomp down on
Miles just like the Velociraptor a
little bit of an air vent in Jurassic
Park now recent promo showcased
preventer prabhakar hey who's the new
guy
this is where the traffic is this is
also where the traffic is the traffic
here too being Spider-Man is so easy I
find a few bad guys commissioner is
voiced by Karen Sony in the English
language version he plays dobinder in
the Deadpool movies I just love the way
he whips his bracelet on a spindle like
a yo-yo and when it flings into the back
of the spot's head it flashes an action
word in Hindi I don't speak Hindi but
I'm pretty sure this is broken or some
version of crack or snap but the best
part of this promo is this quick break
for a try with my my auntie I love chai
tea what did you just say should I teach
I mean Steve you're saying DD to be
honest I did not know that and I will
never get it wrong again I'm so so sorry
but the little animation detail here as
prevention yells at him miles is so
taken aback that he spills the chai and
that tea overflows out of his cup onto
the plate and onto the table now a final
new clip to point out it looks like Jess
Drew's fight with the vulture the
vulture voiced by gormer tacon this will
actually be part of a sequence early in
the movie when Gwen first meets Jess and
me Miguel O'Hara in fact Miguel's line
raging about doctor strange and the
Little Nerd from Earth 1999 is actually
not from the scene from the earlier
trailer that we saw but really part of
this exchange with Gwen I'm sorry who
exactly are you supposed to be isn't it
obvious the blue panther that's funny
don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99 it was Doctor Strange sounds
like he maybe shouldn't practice
medicine
sorry the only Italian I know is from
Mario Kart are you uh oh this we don't
know the sex yet my husband wants it to
be a surprise he's really corny but so
hot guys
will you adopt me what what so it sounds
like this movie is going to open with
two nods to the MCU to Black Panther and
to Doctor Strange in the Tom Holland MCU
Peter Parker now I made a whole video
about this debate over whether the MCU
should be considered 616 or 1999 short
answer is neither yet but the fact that
we're getting the Tom Holland nod early
in the movie structurally to me makes it
likelier that when you get a cameo from
him in the Final Act of the movie after
two hours or so it passed and the
audience hasn't thought about it that
much they're calling the shot early in
the movie to deliver on it at the end
tickets to our May 26 live show in Los
Angeles are still open the first show
sold out but we opened up a second show
for some after dark material ticket
links are in the description and please
subscribe to the Deep dive subscribe to
the break room follow me on Instagram
Twitter
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]